hello lover
in New York they say you're always
looking for a job a boyfriend or an
apartment
since I was 15 I'm exhausted where is he
whoo the White Knight
sometimes it's hard to walk in a single
woman's shoes that's why we need really
special ones to make the walk a little
more fun have you ever been in love
I'm so lutely why do I think
living in Manhattan is so fantastic
because it is there's always a new
neighborhood a new restaurant a new man
maybe you have to let go of who you want
to become who you will be
still gonna have to call it date night
in our 50s I'm a trisexual I'll try
anything once it's all fun and games
till someone has a child
if you find someone to love the you you
love well that's just fabulous
maybe we could be each other's soul
mates
[Music]
the most important thing in life is your
family
sometimes it's the family you're born
into
and sometimes it's the one
you make for yourself
[Music]